[Musique]
erika va régir la réunion rencontré des
élus notre ministre de l'outre-mer si
j'ai
trois demandes de à court terme c'est
que la ministre nous fasse débloquer les
contrats aidés les cae qui ne sont pas
renouvelés parce que les familles
réunionnaises ne peuvent pas se
retrouver à la fin de l'année en leur
disant ça y est c'est fini on ne vous
reconduis pas ça serait passé de très
mauvaises et donc première demande la
deuxième demande pour le département de
la réunion c'est que l' enveloppe de la
dotation exceptionnelle qui sera donné
par l'état pour compenser le rsa et bien
d'autres la réunion d'un montant qui
correspond à la dépense puisque le reste
à charge qu'on appelle par habitant est
supérieure à la moyenne nationale et
puis j'ai une demande à à moyen et long
terme le notre mini spock le projet de
loi sur l'égalité réelle et bah je pense
qu'il faut véritablement qu'on puisse
définir un pacte de croissance
économique que ce que ce projet de loi
de l'égalité réelle nous donne à lire la
vision du gouvernement sur comment créer
de la croissance à la réunion donc de
l'emploi donc de l'activité pour ceux
qui sont au chômage
[Musique]